good news your ps5 alden ring save is
safe we're talking about that and some
steam deck updates
let's start today's episode off with the
game we never talk about on this channel
developer from software has released a
small update for elden ring in the form
of patch
1.02.2 for playstation 5 and pc which
aims to improve gameplay stability in a
blog post the dev apologized for the
inconvenience but said that the new
update should address the common
stability issues that have been reported
since the game launched on february 25th
the patch notes aren't especially long
but do feature fixes for some commonly
reported issues regarding performance on
both consoles and pc for the playstation
5 version changes have been made to the
save game progression even when the game
is not terminated and that's all on the
other hand the patch for the pc version
has fixed the issue where players
graphics cards were not being used thus
resulting in slow performance for
players the developer has also fixed a
bug that was causing the game to quit
under certain circumstances when
fighting the fire giant among other
issues
now let's switch gears to some
unfortunate news following the launch of
valve steam deck recently bungie has
clarified that destiny 2 is not
supported on the machine further stating
that anyone trying to bypass approved
measures for the game will be banned in
a post on the bungie help website the
developer made it clear that quote
destiny is not supported for play on the
steam deck or any other system utilizing
steamplay's proton unless windows is
installed and running players who
attempt to launch destiny 2 on steam
deck through steam os or proton will be
unable to enter the game and will be
returned to their game library after a
short time players who attempt to bypass
destiny 2 incompatibility will be met
with a game ban destiny 2 isn't the only
high profile game not officially
supported on steam deck before this epic
games confirm that the massively popular
battle royale game fortnite is not
natively supported on the machine due to
concerns around cheating and
compatibility issues so instead of
trying destiny 2 on steam deck and
getting banned
try apex legends a new twitter video
shared by user carrie gollum apologies
if i pronounce that wrong in any way has
demonstrated that the first person
battle royale shooter can now be played
on the steam deck the short video shows
apex legends running quite smoothly
while the player runs around looking for
luke last year the steam deck was unable
to run apex legends along with pubg
destiny 2 like we just spoke about and
rainbow six siege it was reported that
the game was incompatible with the
pre-installed steam os due to the
anti-cheat software not activating on
the steam deck's linux based operating
system after valve stated that it would
be improving protons game compatibility
and support for anti-cheat solutions by
working directly with vendors it looks
like the company has resolved some of
these issues just in time for the
release of the steam deck so do you have
a steam deck and if so do you do you
want to just send it to me because i
mean my birthday is this month so like
that'd be that'd be a nice gift if you
let me know in the comments i'll see you
tomorrow
you